what's up guys my name is Chris Appleton
I'm a celebrity hair stylist I'm going
to show you how to get a control top
knot every time put your hair up into a
high ponytail this hair hack is great
for anyone that has a lot of hair and
finds it difficult to get a neat top
knot I'm not going to brush the hair
because obviously we're working with
curves we're going to work some texture
but you want to tie it up get a nice
tight elastic at the base and then it's
a simple splitting your ponytail into
two like so and then you want to cross
it over and put a knot in the hair so
just feed the hair through
into a knot and then tie the ends in
front into a second knot this gives you
a really cute tight little top knot
which is never going to sit out of place
and then you just want to use a couple
of pins just to hold it
and tie those ends in at the back
honestly you can't really go wrong with
this then you're just going to pull out
the edges for a little bit of softness
but it's a great way to get the perfect
top knot every time